[Música]
y lo llaman el techo del mundo
se trata de uno de los lugares más
aislados del planeta
[Música]
rodeado por las montañas más altas de la
tierra el tíbet es un lugar de monjes y
nómadas un espacio congelado en el
tiempo
[Música]
y por eso es tan sorprendente que un
sitio tan misterioso tenga semejante
impacto en la política internacional en
todo el mundo veréis activistas con
maneras de free tibet mientras tanto
china utiliza todo su poder para
mantener esta región como parte de su
territorio pero y por qué es tan
importante el tíbet tienen petróleo
tienen oro pues nada de eso en este
vídeo te lo vamos a contar
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la primera pregunta que yo siempre me
hecho con el tíbet es
un pensó que era una buena idea
asentarse en el tíbet quiero decir quién
fue el primer genio porque hay que ser
un genio que allá por el paleolítico
dijo apá y si cruzamos las montañas que
por cierto son las más altas del mundo y
montamos una civilización al otro lado y
el amigo le respondió no hay web pues si
montar una civilización por ahí nos
parece suficiente los tibetanos
construyeron más de 6000 templos
budistas en los lugares más inaccesibles
del planeta tierra y parte del
extranjero si alguien ve este vídeo
desde bilbao
lo siento os han ganado por goleada pero
lo cierto es que hay muchas cosas
inexplicables en el tíbet lo primero que
tenemos que saber es que en realidad el
tíbet significa tres cosas distintas por
un lado está el altiplano tibetano que
es una meseta varias veces el tamaño de
francia que se levanta a cinco mil
metros por encima del nivel del mar y
que está rodeada por las montañas más
altas del mundo el himalaya por otro
lado está el tíbet como entidad cultural
que aquí entra en otros países como
nepal o bután pero en este vídeo vamos a
centrarnos en éste tíbet
[Música]
la región autónoma del tíbet como su
propio nombre sugiere se trata de una
región autónoma dentro de la república
popular de china pero no os equivoquéis
por mucho que lo diga el nombre el tíbet
tiene muy poco de autónomo en realidad
está dominado con mano de hierro por
beijing es más muchos tibetanos ni
siquiera pueden conseguir un pasaporte
lo que significa que no pueden viajar al
extranjero su lengua nativa está
prohibida y casi todos esos 6.000
monasterios que había en el pasado están
destruidos pero por desgracia nada de
esto os va a sorprender es china de
hecho los tibetanos no son la única
minoría oprimida por beijing sin embargo
el tíbet tiene un espacio especial en la
política internacional y diréis porque
pues principalmente por este señor
el dalai lama' gana el premio nobel de
la paz noticia del año 1989 el dalai
lama es el líder religioso del budismo
tibetano y el líder del gobierno
tibetano en el exilio básicamente este
hombre quiere que el tíbet se separe de
china pero a no ser que viváis en una
cueva todo esto ya lo sabéis todo el
mundo conoce al dalai lama para que
sabéis una idea en el año 2013 una
consultora que se llama harris hizo una
encuesta para descubrir cuáles eran los
líderes políticos más conocidos del
mundo el dalai lama estaba en primer
lugar junto a barack obama y todo esto
es sorprendente si tenemos en cuenta que
el tíbet tiene poco más de 3 millones de
habitantes y está en uno de los lugares
más inaccesibles del planeta en
condiciones normales el tíbet podría ser
uno de esos lugares desconocidos donde
si se violan los derechos humanos pero
tampoco te importa habéis visto alguna
vez a alguien protestar a favor de los
derechos de la minoría uigur pues
seguramente ni siquiera sepáis quién son
los uigures sin embargo la campaña del
free tibet ha ganado el apoyo de famosos
de hollywood como richard gere donde yo
vivo en praga
hay banderas de free tibet por toda la
ciudad y si pensabais que llevar estas
banderas no trae ninguna consecuencia
política error craso error atentos
bangladesh cubre unas obras de arte
tibetano tras las quejas de china
la venganza de china por el apoyo de
praga al tíbet chino- se queja a los
legisladores de eeuu por una visita del
dalai lama y lo más curioso de todo esto
es que china tiene muchísimos otros
problemas
queréis conflictos territoriales pues
tenéis la disputa con japón en el mar
del este de china
queréis problemas con minorías oprimidas
podéis leer sobre la minoría uigur si
mis queridos amigos de visual política
el tíbet está lejos de ser el único
dolor de cabeza de china pero por alguna
razón en beijing se toman este problema
muy en serio simplemente el mero hecho
de hablar del tíbet está prohibido en
china y fuera del país mencionar el
dalai lama' delante de un político chino
es sinónimo de tener problemas
diplomáticos
[Música]
y os preguntaréis pero porque es una
cuestión económica pues para nada
ivette es la región más pobre de china
es por algo relacionado con el petróleo
pues tampoco entonces porque china está
tan preocupada por el tíbet porque el
resto del mundo está tan preocupado por
el tíbet qué derecho tiene china para
ocupar este territorio hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
el último lugar de la tierra os dice
algo el nombre de tenzin gyatso pues
este es el nombre del dalai lama en
realidad decir taray lama es como decir
el papá y el papá es la cabeza de la
iglesia católica el dalai lama es la
cabeza del budismo tibetano y de igual
forma que el papá es el jefe del estado
vaticano y de la santa sede el dalai
lama es el líder político del gobierno
tibetano en el exilio
[Música]
y aquí viene un dato curioso cuantos
años creéis que tenía nuestro amigo
tenzin gyatso cuando le nombraron dalai
lama
la respuesta es 55 años habéis oído bien
el cargo de dalai lama ni se elige por
voto ni se hereda el cargo de dalai lama
ni se elige por voto ni se hereda el
dalai lama es la reencarnación de una
diosa cuyo nombre impronunciable no sé
si me atrevo a pronunciar venga lo voy a
intentar pero si alguien ve este vídeo y
habla tibetano ya pido disculpas de
antemano el nombre es aval o quites vara
pues bien cada vez que un dalai lama
muere las autoridades religiosas buscan
al humano en lo que se ha reencarnado y
diréis y como lo encuentran pues yo no
tengo ni idea tendréis que preguntarles
a ellos pero cuando encuentran al
auténtico dalai lama le coronan como rey
del tíbet y así es como reinará en el
país hasta que se reencarne en otro de
la isla
este es el sistema político en el que se
ha basado el tíbet desde el año mil 391
mientras tanto el tíbet ha sido
conquistado por los mongoles y por los
chinos pero siempre ha mantenido este
sistema que combina feudalismo con
teocracia simplemente los monarcas
tibetanos los dalai lamas pagaban un
tributo a los mongoles oa los chinos en
otras palabras que durante siglos casi
nadie se preocupó en serio por este
lugar ni para bien ni para mal
para que os hagáis una idea el tíbet ha
estado tan aislado que incluso el
budismo que es la religión por la que
todos conocemos este lugar no llegó
hasta el siglo 7 después de cristo esto
es más de 1000 años después del
nacimiento de esta religión y todo esto
explica porque hasta hace muy poco
tiempo el tíbet llegó a tener más de 600
mil monjes y monjas en una población de
25 millones de habitantes pero todo esto
cambió en el siglo 20 primero entre 1912
y 1950 las dinastías chinas se retiraron
del tíbet parecía que este país iba a
ser soberano para siempre pero como ya
sabéis todos el destino le reservaba a
otros planes a los pobres tibetanos
la política es como la guerra pero sin
derramamiento de sangre la guerra es
como la política pero con derramamiento
de sangre mao tse tung el 6 de octubre
de 1950 el ejército de liberación chino
cruzó el himalaya y derrotó al ejército
tibetano como os podéis imaginar no
hacía falta ser un genio para ganar esta
guerra por aquel entonces china tenía
550 millones de habitantes y el tíbet
poco menos de 2,5 millones el gobierno
tibetano llevaba años completamente
aislado del resto del mundo con lo que
no tenían ni aliados ni nadie que se
preocupara por ellos así que por muy
fácil de defender que fuera el
territorio tibetano conquistar les fue
un juego de niños y hablando de niños el
14º dalai lama' que es el mismo que
tenemos hoy en día tenía ya 16 años
[Música]
ya os podéis imaginar su preparación
política así que envió una delegación a
beijing para negociar un acuerdo de paz
la delegación en cuestión ni siquiera
pudo comunicarse con él una vez llegaron
a china así que llegaron a un acuerdo de
17 puntos en el que china se anexiona va
el tíbet con unas condiciones un tanto
discutible es cierto el tíbet podía
conservar su sistema político el llamado
cazar pero siempre y cuando aceptaran la
autoridad china y ya sé lo que estaréis
pensando el principio no suena tan mal
no es nada nuevo que no hubieran tenido
durante siglos en el tíbet es más es una
autonomía similar a la que tenía hong
kong hasta hace unos pocos meses el
problema del programa está en los
detalles
[Aplausos]
tan sólo una parte del tíbet tenía esa
autonomía pero todas las regiones del
este del país formarían parte de china
todo esto significa que vivirían y
sufrirían las reformas maoístas y
creedme a nadie le gustaría vivir las
reformas de mahou así que los habitantes
de estas regiones se rebelaron contra el
partido comunista chino y así es como en
el año 1959
mao tse tung dijo éstos tibetanos este
les das la mano y te cogen el brazo
entero me parece que le vamos a tener
que dar un poco de ya sabes liberación
el 17 de marzo de 1959 la artillería
china atacó el palacio del dalai lama y
éste tuvo que escapar a la india como os
podéis imaginar muchos tibetanos
salieron a protestar y muchas de estas
protestas se volvieron violentas y grace
como reacción a beijing pues siguiendo
el método tradicional del partido
comunista chino en otras palabras la
represión más bestia y salvaje que os
podáis imaginar lo que viene después nos
va a sorprender pensando bien hablamos
de finales de los años 50
de la guerra fría por un lado tenemos a
un país comunista invadiendo otro país
no comunista en otras palabras una
ventana de oportunidad magnífica para
[Música]
según los archivos la fia ayudó a los
tibetanos en el exilio en los años 60 o
que sorpresa nadie se esperaba a la cia
verdad
exactamente eeuu armó a los rebeldes
tibetanos y le dio unas pingües
subvenciones al dalai lama la cia se
gastó más de un millón setecientos mil
dólares al año para apoyar la causa del
tíbet libre 500 mil dólares iban para
armar las guerrillas y otros 180.000
iban directos para el dalai lama y así
es como un conflicto regional se
convirtió en una causa a nivel mundial
de repente el mundo entero descubrió el
dalai lama y el free tibet se convirtió
en un eslogan repetido en todo el
planeta tierra desde su exilio en la
india el dalai lama' creó la librería
tibetana y gracias a esto hoy en día
todos conocemos el budismo tibetano
seguro pendiente tenéis en casa un
mandala tibetano o tenéis el típico
amigo espiritual que tiene flores de
loto budistas en su casa si buscáis en
google encontrareis montones de webs y
de periódicos de apoyo al tíbet y por
supuesto el budismo tibetano ha causado
auténtico furor en hollywood atentos
sacando el tíbet estás salvando la
posibilidad de que todos seamos hermanos
y hermanas richard gere steven seagal
héroes del cine de acción y lama
tibetano por cierto que como dato
curioso os diré que toda esta ayuda de
eeuu se frenó en seco en 1972 y diréis
porque pues porque ese es el momento en
el que la casa blanca empezó a trabajar
relaciones diplomáticas con china y ya
sé lo qué pensaréis muchos lo sabía todo
esto del free tibet es una conspiración
de la cia para desestabilizar a china
ahora me siento tan desengañado voy a
quemar mi mándala a ver por favor deja
el mandala en su sitio y sigue por el
vídeo alma de cántaro el hecho de que la
cia estuviera envuelta en la causa del
tíbet no significa que china no haya
hecho cosas malas para nada la última
revuelta del tíbet terminó en el año
1962 para entonces se estima que el
ejército chino destruyó más de 6 mil
templos tibetanos y mató a más de 87.000
los tibetanos
[Música]
pero no sólo eso en los años 60 china
sufrió la revolución cultural de mao
todo esto significa que 15 años más
tarde había sólo 8 monasterios en pie
habéis oído bien 8 monasterios donde
antes había 6000 según algunas
estimaciones en 1950 había 600 mil
monjas y monjes en el tíbet para 1979
todos habían sido ejecutados y la
pregunta es por qué qué interés tiene
china en el tíbet pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
[Música]
[Aplausos]
el eje de asia porque china está tan
interesada en el tíbet incluso hoy en
día el tíbet es la región más pobre de
las 31 regiones de china y la población
guarda un enorme resentimiento contra
beijing pues la respuesta es simple y a
la vez complicada fijaos en este mapa
[Música]
os dais cuenta aquí podéis ver todos los
ríos que nacen del altiplano tibetano
aquí está el río yangtsé y el río
amarillo los dos ríos más importantes de
toda china pero también está el río
mekong del que beben en laos camboya y
vietnam el río irrawaddy es el principal
río nyan mar y por supuesto aquí también
nace el brahmaputra y el ganges lo
entendéis ahora y controla el tibet
controla casi todo el agua dulce de asia
y esto es casi la mitad del agua que se
bebe en el mundo y como os podéis
imaginar china sabe muy bien cómo
utilizar un recurso tan estratégico
[Música]
si no termino la planta hidroeléctrica
más grande del tíbet en este momento
china tiene alrededor de 87 mil pantanos
en todo su territorio pues bien dos
terceras partes de estos pantanos están
en el tíbet pero no sólo eso en el año
2007 el gobierno chino también encontró
enormes depósitos minerales cobre oro
plomo y zinc podríamos hablar de la
mitad del cobre y del zinc de toda china
por supuesto que todas estas
explotaciones tienen sus problemas
medioambientales y a la india no le hace
ninguna gracia que china controle casi
toda su agua
pero ya sé lo que estaréis pensando en
principio no tendría por qué ser tan
malo para los tibetanos verdad quiero
decir que te invada china no es plato de
gusto para nadie todo esto es verdad
pero las penas pasan mejor si china te
trae dinero y trabajos no os parece
seamos honestos antes de la invasión
china el tíbet no era ningún paraíso
precisamente y sin grace las
estadísticas el pib del tíbet ha estado
creciendo a ritmo de dos dígitos por 25
años eso es mucho dinero y muchos
trabajos donde está el problema de que
se quejan los tibetanos pues el problema
está en la raza
[Música]
y amigos de visual político la raza en
china importa mucho más de lo que creéis
y casi todos estos trabajos que trae el
progreso chino van para la gente de
etnia china que ha emigrado al tíbet el
90% de la población de esta región son
étnicamente tibetanos sólo el 8%
pertenece a la etnia hand que es la raza
mayoritaria en el resto de china
prácticamente todos ellos son chinos que
han emigrado el pib para trabajar y esos
son los que consiguen los mejores
empleos el resto de tibetanos siguen
siendo pobres en otras palabras que si
eres de etnia tibetana esto es lo que te
llega de la modernización
los nómadas tibetanos desplazados
forzosamente por china se resigna a
perder la tradición de más de ocho mil
años o esto
los tibetanos lamentan que las minas
chinas contaminan sus tierras sagradas
los aldeanos dicen que una gran mina de
litio no solo profana las tierras
sagradas sino que además genera una
contaminación letal el río solía estar
lleno de peces y ahora no tiene ninguno
cientos de yaks han muerto en los
últimos años después de beber agua del
río según un censo de la universidad de
beijing sólo el 1 por ciento de los
tibetanos habrían emigrado al resto de
china en 2010 y los pocos que lo
lograron lo tiene muy difícil para
encontrar un trabajo en ciudades como
beijing o shanghai básicamente si eres
tibetano apenas tienes oportunidades ni
en casa ni en el resto de china y todo
esto explica por qué pese a los
esfuerzos de china para acabar con la
cultura tibetana todavía hay tanta gente
que sigue al dalai lama por otra parte
el actual dalai lama es muy distinto de
sus predecesores veréis ha pasado la
mayor parte de su vida fuera del tíbet
ha estado años entre los líderes
occidentales y todo esto ha influido sus
ideas políticas de forma radical
el dalai lama' declara el éxito de la
democracia tibetana y cede el poder al
líder electo tibetano todo esto
significa que si algún día al dalai
lama' vuelve al tíbet ya no será el
monarca teocrático que algún día fue
esta vez apoyar a un gobierno
democrático con su parlamento y su líder
elegido por sufragio universal sin
embargo por el momento no parece que
china vaya a permitirlo así que ahora la
pregunta es para vosotros creéis que
algún día los tibetanos van a recuperar
su estilo de vida y su cultura volverá
el dalai lama' a pisar el suelo tibetano
llegaremos a ver un tíbet independiente
podeis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribimos a visual
política y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]